if i could cancel or wipe away
or if i could just do the snap that
thanos did i would get rid of every
franchise reboot
post probably
92.
if you were the head of a movie studio
what five movies would you green light
right now
well um if i was head of a movie studio
and i could green light five movies
i don't know if it's cheating
but i would green light three movies
which would be to redo the sequel
trilogy to star wars
i mean maybe that could count as one
but um i feel it was such a
dissatisfying end to
i guess what was intended to be a nine
film saga although
who knows when you're watching this
maybe they'll do 12 films
uh there'll be another
star wars trilogy but i i i would i
would green like that because that's a
safe bet
and we would we would
do it right this time um
the other thing i would do is probably
probably confederacy of dunces i think
is a is a classic book
that um
you know a a lot of people have
you know there have been false starts to
getting that
made that book turned into a movie
another one would be the chuck palahniuk
book survivor
which is a
probably you know
you know
one of his greatest books has such an
incredible scene
set during the super bowl
that if it's ever committed a film will
be incredible i don't really know how
you could
really make survey survivor would have
to be done almost in the way of fight
club
you know just like with a big budget and
just like not care uh what people think
but it's it's about a guy telling his
story into the flight recorder of a
plane where he's allowed he's taken his
plane hostage um he's this spiritual
guru
who has had been in trouble with the law
who now
has commandeered a plane
you know and gotten everyone off the
plane so he is literally telling his
life story into the flight recorder
and it's what he's saying into the
flight recorder that's the story being
told
um
brilliant it's it's a book that i will
read every couple years just to
just to remind myself
that this is what can happen in in
writing it's amazing so i would i would
green like chuck
green light chuck palinx
survivor
which is famously
where the the the phrase suicide girls
came from
that that name
is you know the website
was named after a line in that book
um is it that those type it's sort of a
gossip yeah it's sort of like oh those
suicide girls and uh the founders of the
suicide girls website
took uh you know that line that inspired
like oh we're going to start a website
based on that
um
so that would be one that i would do
uh
i you know i i'd like to see
i don't know that a studio needs to do
this i would like to see a documentary
about marcia lucas
marsha lucas
had such a profound impact
on
on filmmaking in the 70s you know she
was just respected by everyone from
francis ford coppola to martin scorsese
to
her husband george lucas there would not
be a george lucas if not for marsha
lucas
there's never been a deep dive i believe
documentary about her speaking today
about
you know i i
you can almost see there's like
hollywood before marcia lucas and after
marsha lucas the impact that she had
um
there's a there's a
rare and i've never seen it but i've
read articles about a rare rough cut of
the first assembly of star wars black
and white you know taken from you know
the dailies they cut it together and
it's just like and it's
an unwatchable film it's terrible
the original star wars i mean there's
like inappropriate humor which kind of
reared its head again in
episode one the phantom menace
but you can see the the choices that
marcia cut things out there are things
where just a few frames are cut and it
changes the dynamic of a character as
seen
in the cantina bar at most at most
eisley
before
you know luke skywalker and obi-wan
kenobi meet with han solo and chewbacca
han solo's sitting with this attractive
woman
and just sitting with her and she gets
up and walks away marsha lucas cut some
frames she's not there she's not even in
the movie
she
saved that film in the editing many of
the special effects in the original star
wars the reason they're so impactful is
because they're not on screen for very
long
so at the time that
that came out i mean it was it was so
fast paced
and a lot of the effects objectively
didn't work but because they were on
screen for so brief a moment
it worked so i'd love to see a
documentary about marsha lucas
that really
really details her contribution to film
not just star wars but you know how she
was so
widely re respected you know by all the
greatest directors of the 70s um you
know and then after
her parting ways with george
um
you know she was basically ostracized i
mean she was you know working with her
was
she was just out of hollywood at that
point
um
so
that one is a huge shame
i'm trying to think of others there's
just
so many i would like to see um
the comic book
the dark knight returns
by frank miller that four-issue series
you know
zack snyder
was inspired by that when he made batman
v superman
the thing that made the dark knight
returns so compelling was that
it it had all this history in it
it would be great to see that comic book
turned and turned into a film
um
another one
and maybe someone from marvel
is uh
is
if someone from marvel
watches this or listening listens to
this this is a comic book that no one
knows about
i bring up every once in a while it's a
comic book called strikeforce moratori
and it's about a group of people
that have superpowers they the
that um it's in a far future
of
of the world where aliens invade and
they're
slaughtering humans and the humans are
losing
so
there's a program that's developed to
give people superpowers there's only one
catch you only live for about a year
so you don't know what kind of
superpower you're going to get
you don't know how you're going to help
in this battle against these aliens
these invading aliens
but uh
you only get to live for a year so
you're you're
putting your life on the line and
sometimes you don't even live that long
so it focuses on the second group of
heroes that have gone through this
process
um it's it's a series that that marvel
did uh back in the 80s never forgot that
story that it was really impactful um
filled with pathos and drama
um a whole group of i mean it was you
know it just a whole diverse group of
characters all this like the the the
world's at stake um but it wouldn't
really fit into the marvel universe at
all it's you know because it's just sort
of the separate
universe
but i'd love to see that
i guess if i'm a hollywood executive i'm
green lighting big budget
you know franchise films
so um maybe the marsha lucas documentary
wouldn't necessarily fit into that all
that well
but
you know god there's just so many i i'd
i'd love to see
love to see made
what would you cancel
well i would have canceled
probably maybe the
last five years of franchise reboots
there has
almost universally not been one that's
succeeded in a way where everyone is
like that was awesome
i mean
you know just a quick example like for
example lord of the rings
the lord of the rings trilogy not the
hobbit the lord of the rings
we don't really talk about that that
series of movies so much
the reason is there's no debate there's
no debate
people who don't like lord of the rings
i'm not a fantasy film fan
right and i wasn't a lord of the rings
fan necessarily i remember the hobbit
cartoon
by rankin bass
back in the day which used wrote an
early form of rotoscoping which is
interesting but but i was not a fan of
lord of the rings per se and that movie
made me that series of movies made me a
fan
you know it's incredible we don't really
debate about that because there's not
that much debate they're objectively
amazing films if you're a hardcore
tolkien fan yes there are nitpicks but
there's almost no debate about it but i
don't know that we'll ever stop debating
the disappointment that
um that was that star wars sequel
trilogy i feel like
that is a debate that will just continue
i just wonder will hollywood learn the
lessons i would want to go back in
almost every franchise that was rebooted
um ghostbusters
terminator dark fate
uh you know
there's so many um
you know
did we need more fast and the furious
movies
you know i i i don't know
it it seems to me that these that these
franchise reboots i mean in some cases
there has too much time has elapsed
between you know they want to do another
film and and whatnot it's just because
the branding exists right there's that
recognition you know like
when they
you know like when they
name
a movie after a familiar song
right like that's sort of a laziness on
the part of on the part of hollywood but
yeah i would if i could cancel or wipe
away
or if i could just do the snap that
thanos did i would get rid of every
franchise reboot
post probably
92.
what about a star is born
did you see the first one
yeah a star is born well that see but
it's such a different approach
because there's
you know
it's the music world has changed
it's about being invested in those
characters
um
that i don't really think fits in that
category i think that star is born is
just a classic story
that's just like okay it's this is
familiar the bottles from familiar we're
gonna put like maybe a slight different
flavor you know i like those they have
those different flavors of coke like
vanilla cherry cherry vanilla orange
coke lime coke they do make that um
so it's familiar but with like a a twist
and
yeah i mean
that that
stars born movie with bradley cooper and
lady gaga is pretty damn incredible
um
you know
i i really don't have much to say about
that one
you know except
good job bradley cooper
as the head of a movie studio what would
be your mission
and what would it be called by the way
what would your studio oh well yes it
would be called gore film okay that
would be my movie studio
and
i i would
i mean look
you have to tell stories where
it's an amazing story without the
superficial elements right
there has to be something to say about
you know
our current climate
we live in such divided times
i don't know why there are so
few films about that
why are we so divided
why is it that people
living in the same country who all want
the same things what are wh why are we
so divided
now and there are
so few films that are dedicated to that
you know i i do see a lot of
documentaries and generally
the documentary films of a political
nature are generally they're on the left
or they're on the right
and it's it's really disappointing
because
as the viewer i would like to be able to
come to my own conclusion rather to be
led into one that you determined before
you started making the movie
so i'm surprised that
when you look at the kind of issues that
films from the 70s you know were taking
on very challenging
issues
i don't know why we're not doing that
now
so much of hollywood now is about
dictating some sort of predetermined
message it's not entertaining
i don't mind if some of that is is woven
in
but i do mind being told how to think
and i i think it that if if i was head
of a studio i'd not be telling my
audience how to think and i would
certainly be listening to what the
audience
wants
and maybe giving them something they
didn't expect that i hope they really
like
but certainly not pounding them over the
head with some sort of agenda
you know uh i i think i think we're more
alike than we are different and i don't
know why
we're not reminded of that
so that would that would be my mission
and to tell original stories giving
opportunity to small indie filmmakers
to tell original stories taking some
risks not every science fiction movie
needs to have
over the top spectacle with the fate of
the universe at stake
when you look back at some of the old
star trek episodes
there's so few special effects shots
right it's
star trek really delved into the realm
of ideas
and i'd like to see science fiction come
back to
dealing in the realm of big ideas
and you don't always need big spectacle
or big budgets to tell those stories
so do you think hollywood can learn
lessons from let's say art house cinema
or foreign films where there's a
subtlety there may still be a message
but it's it's letting it breathe it's
letting the viewer discover it whether
they're going to agree with it or not
whereas maybe in western culture we're
beating them over the head it's so overt
that there's no hiding it that it's
forced i i'm just curious what yeah i
think i think we've forgotten you know
joseph campbell and the hero's journey
you know i i
you know
i guess
so much of
films today seem like they kind of want
to break that mold there's a reason that
mold works it's kind of embedded in
human dna
you know that kind of around the fire
storytelling
is is universal
and
that seems to
seems to have been forgotten
lately
um in trying to break that mold
i'm just i'm just
you know especially when we see you know
the hero's journey for so many female
lead characters i think a disservice is
being done to
um
people who look up to those characters
because it's made to look easy
people forget how much failure there has
been in some of the iconic movie
characters everyone from luke skywalker
to
rocky people forget in the original
rocky film
rocky loses
he loses the fight now he gains respect
which is more of what that film is about
but he lost the fight in the original
raiders of the lost ark
indiana jones loses
he's tied up
his only logic is i'm going to close my
eyes to not to not get caught up in
these evil spirits that are coming out
to murder everything right he kind of
loses i mean maybe he wins in the end
because he gets he gets the ark he
doesn't really get the ark because it's
tucked away in a giant warehouse but he
loses
there's something about
losing and this happens
more in indie films than it does in
hollywood movies
you know what happened in the empire
strikes back luke lost
he lost the fight he lost his hand
you have to i really feel like if it's
not tied to character i don't know how
the events of that film really can be
meaningful if it's not tied to some hero
character journey that you're on where
you can because we all fail in life
believe me we all fail in life
life is just i mean look it's just
learning from your failures right i mean
that's
and
i've made plenty of mistakes in my
personal and professional life
um that i've paid for and i like to
think i'm who i am today is better
that's that's just failures failure is
how we learn and i feel like by not
imbuing that lesson
we're doing a disservice to
young moviegoers who might look up to
these heroes it really is um
it's kind of a disappointing time to see
how franchises are being
you know
[Music]
twisted in a way that i don't think
serves the audience but but there's
something to be said for losing
characters that lose more often than
they win
and what exactly you win i think rocky
probably being the most
obvious or best example of that because
then they just made rocky too sylvester
stallone made rocky too
and the oh it's pretty much the same
movie i mean there's some little fun
differences in it but but it's the same
movie but he wins in that one he
actually wins the fight
but it's kind of the same movie they
just revisit a lot of the same stuff in
the film but but he wins
whatever but the fact that rocky lost
but he won he had a girlfriend adrian
he'd want a girlfriend even though he's
kind of this simpleton right this sort
of thug
but anyone respect it wasn't about
winning that fight it was about winning
respect and that was tied to him in his
humanity and his soul and his character
and being that's why they made so many
rocky movies because that character's so
endearing
you know and and we're on that journey
that constant constant failure until the
end and then he wins the fight but but
in the first one he lost and and
almost no one remembers that if you ask
right now ask any
person you see like who won the fight in
the first rocky and it was iraqi won the
fight no he didn't
you